[Music]
hello everybody what's up wait a minute
three girls one wife something is
missing this guy there's my
boy I know you love your D go up say it
d
yes of course he loves you he just he
just doesn't show it on his face or with
his body language right Brew junor come
on grw I need a word with you your
family's lives are at stake
what maxal has escaped from pison I'm
coming for my revenge
group we have to get to the safe house
it
has I love this place
look she the most important part of a
heist is being aware of potential
dangers
she I Tred
[Music]
myself
watch out watch out watch out watch out
no
what
intrud
aha
thanks
Ron fire in
[Music]
the
p